another day something something happened
after they started recycling
and they got to the ayah
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
his son was known as one who if he had
the quran he would be affected
a lot to the extent that he would fall
unconscious so his father forbade when
he did salah
if he saw his son ali was praying behind
him he was short in the prayer he would
recite a little bit
because he knew his son would be
affected so much so one day in for vain
he didn't know ali was behind him and he
lent them the prayer
and he said al-fudail
so ali was behind him and ali cried and
cried and cried and he felt unconscious
and then after salah ali's mother came
she said to further one day you're going
to kill our son
and then what happened another day
something something happened and for
they started recycling
and they got to the ayah
event
[Music]
ali started crying crying crying and he
took his last breath
and he felt her grind he died this is
the effect the quran
upon them so we're not saying that quran
what we're saying is that the quran
shall shake our hearts
but we need to be present when the quran
is being recited
you